my guest has been on the show before
when he was promoting the documentary
cocaine Cowboys a few years ago his 3430
on the you is some must-see stuff so is
screwball the documentary film about the
biogenesis scandal from his native miami
florida good to see you Billy Corgan how
are you brother I'm great thanks so
let's get into this thing right here
this documentary is about the Toni Bosch
scandal that got a rod a year's
suspension Manny Ramirez got popped and
Melky Cabrera got popped why did you
make this documentary Billy actually in
November of 2013 we were pitched by Alex
Rodriguez oh okay so this you're
laughing already at that hey what okay
cuz they can this documentary is not
very what's the word for it's not very
complimentary to Alex getting an
invitation to the wedding if that's what
you mean right yeah so but it's also
extremely accurate it's all very true
it's all exactly how it happened well I
mean the stories are being that you're
being told by Toni Bosch or dr. Toni
Bosch you were factors quotes in quotes
who was the one who was at the center of
all of this and his dad was the one
who's writing the prescriptions for
these drugs and and also the fella
Porter Fisher who was the one who leaked
the documents the whistleblower the
whistleblower if you will and these guys
are telling the story from their own
first-person and your unique way in
which you you have them tell their
stories we'll get to in a second but
this is absolutely straight from the
horse's mouth that we're seeing right
here yeah first person why did Alex
Rodriguez pitch you the scientist so in
November of 2013 he was in the midst of
the arbitration with MLB he was the only
one of the players involved in the
biogenesis scandal that appealed his
suspension I guess why not what'd he
have to lose it was the longest
suspension in the history of the games
111 games he went for it and so he took
a break from that arbitration and came
down to his office in Coral Gables in
the suburb very affluent suburb of Miami
where the University of Miami is
actually located Alex Rodriguez field is
located and his publicist hit me up and
said Alex would like to meet with you to
discuss the possibility of doing a
tell-all documentary and I was like hell
I'll take that meeting yeah I thought
we're gonna do it real hush-hush and
quiet at his office and it turns out
they wanted to meet us on a weekday at
high noon at the most popular restaurant
in town like the Power Lunch spot of
Coral Gables which is like two miles
from um which if any anywhere I'm gonna
get recognized because of the you
documentaries it's gonna be not
proximity to um and so it was very clear
that my producing partner Alfred
Spellman and I were attended that event
as like pawns in Alex's kind of PR
offensive against MLB at the time you
remember it was like they were in a
battle of the legacies Bud Selig and
Alex I mean yeah there was a whole story
about how the protesters outside were
actually paid for by Alex Rodriguez I
know if that was ever absolutely sultry
meant it okay yeah so yeah and it was it
was ugly there was no other way to
describe it you notice I think Major
League Baseball has become like I think
everything else in American life
including politics
it's the WWE you know and back when Bud
Selig the steroid commissioner was on
his way out the door on the eve of his
retirement was kind of like well maybe I
should do something about this now that
this scandal has erupted in 2013 he
talks to his second command Rob Manfred
and says let's look like we're doing
something about this so they come down
to Miami have this farcical
investigation that involves the MLB
investigators they have like this
internal FBI of like former cops they go
they sleep with a former nurse of Toni
Bosch at one of his clinics they're
paying people off they've got a slush
fund of 125,000 grand that they're
buying stolen medical records in a diner
from a convicted felon the whole thing
is just utterly absurd and then they
nail Alex cuz what bigger scalp did you
get then Alex Rodriguez and then bud
retires Rob Manfred takes over and he
goes well what's the storyline now what
better than to make a heal a hero and
bring back not only a rod but you know
but Charlie hustle to the game to become
commentators and Pete Rose and who's not
there anymore of course but like and it
worked I mean it's a bottom-line company
and and and it's a brilliant storyline
now are you saying Major League Baseball
was Orchestra has orchestrated
- well what used to be 2/5 of the people
on the set of Fox baseball you're saying
I'm saying that it's it's awfully
convenient and it's awfully brilliant I
think Alex is spectacularly good at that
job knock his hustle at all he's you
know and so he's earned that position he
certainly lightened up he's a lot
funnier a lot more self-effacing
certainly more so than the guy I met for
lunch
in November of 2013 who was in you know
a battle for his life his legacy his
career his livelihood and who spent an
hour hour and a half just lying right to
our faces about everything ever meeting
Toni Bosch ever cheating or using
performance-enhancing drugs at that
stage of his career it was a pretty wild
meeting and needless to say after that
we didn't hear back much from them I was
gonna ask you Billy Everly the director
of screwball about the biogenesis
scandal again in theaters Friday and
then numerous streaming platforms the
following Friday after that how did the
meeting with a-rod finish up I mean what
happened with just more lies basically
and so we walked away I thought he was a
fascinating guy really a fragile guy a
sensitive guy at the time not much of a
sense of humor or sell any sense of
self-awareness but I thought what a
compelling character to be able to
examine to interview and I emailed them
for the next six seven eight months the
the arbitration resolved in January of
2014 he got a sentence reduction if he
will but still I think a season long
suspension and so by the middle of 2014
it seemed obvious that they were not
really interested in in participating in
an interview or a documentary and and
why not the strategy has paid off this
whole kind of head-in-the-sand ignored
and it'll go away strategy has certainly
worked for them I think it's one of the
most remarkable image rehabilitations in
the history of public relations it's not
just that though I mean he had he did
come out and when he did show back up
with the with the Yankees he came out
and threw himself basically on on the
the sword I mean he did come out and
give a complete total maiya culpa he
went and made fun of himself on the
stage at the ESPYs I mean he has had as
you pointed out he said no sense of
humor about himself or anything like
that he has seen too
take a total reverse pivot on how he has
portrayed himself or how he has taken on
what he did absolutely okay you taking I
wouldn't say he did a much of a Maher
culpa tour he didn't really acknowledge
what he did or didn't do what he lied
about the other players like Ryan Braun
that he threw under the bus that his
camp deliberately leaked in order to
take some of the attention away from him
in the thick of the scandal I don't
think he really vest up to it I don't
think he has to I mean obviously doesn't
have to but I'm just saying I don't
think he really did any kind of
comprehensive apology or discussion
about I think how profoundly
disappointing it was for legions of
young kids who look up to these athletes
as heroes and role models so then
somebody who did speak with him when he
was at a low point yeah and then as you
point out you think you were used as a
prop or used in a certain way physically
I'm totally cool with that they spelled
my name right in page six it was in bold
I don't have the juice to make that
happen
thank you Alex thank you Jimmy's
publicist this is all just setting up
the ultimate question and I think a lot
of fans are wondering hearing this if
they already weren't wondering it to
begin with and who's the Alex Rodriguez
that we're seeing today I think a
liberated man I think this was a guy who
was kind of trapped by his own kind of
failed persona in baseball who was booed
by his own fans in baseball never really
a beloved pop culture figure I think a
guy who was almost in a way liberated
when he hit rock bottom in this scandal
and now feels free to I hope this is him
meaning like I think maybe that this is
the you know the person he was always
supposed to be and always wanted to be
but felt constrained by fame and fortune
and of course when you're generating
that kind of revenue over four hundred
million dollars over a career you have
so many people around you who rely on
you and so you don't really have a
chance to kind of free yourself and go
out in public and and and feel like you
could joke around and just be you and I
I think I think it's liberating for
someone to be out of the game like the
only game he's the only thing he's ever
known the only thing he's ever been told
he's good at and the interesting thing
about screwball is it turns out it's not
about Alex Rodriguez don't tell him that
but it's not about a
it's about these bizarre Elmore Leonard
Carl Hiaasen almost Coen Brothers esque
characters it's a career to put in habit
this only in Miami kind of world and
it's the weirdest birdcage I've ever
seen bizarre and you can't make it up
because it's it's it's nonsense family
ending you know who's in drag who's Gene
Hackman I know you're talking about Toni
Bosch who is at the center of all of us
who was the one who was dispensing all
of the the steroids using his dad's
script paper pad doctor write a legit
doctor and then this fella Porter Fisher
who was just uh I don't know what what
what do you describe him the one who was
the one who gave the who stole the he
essentially took the documents from Toni
Bosch we just let it lying around the
biogenesis office took them and sent
them to the press yep because he was
pissed about not getting $4,000 back
it's an you know it's a chunk of change
a nice chunk of change but even Toni
Bosch and your doc your honor he said he
wishes he had paid that money to avoid
everything else did it happen it's
insane I think I'm more interested in
hearing how you described Porter Fisher
after having watched the vacuum is one
would just be a sad figure who's just
looking for some sort of relevance you
know that's what I and he found it be in
these documents and he took these
documents from so he stole the documents
from Toni Bosch and then the documents
were stolen from him and sold not just
to the highest bidder but every bitter I
mean anybody willing to pay anything for
them and including major league baseball
who paid 125 thousand cash in a diner
out of some slush fund I presume I don't
think they were gonna 1099 the convicted
felon that they were buying these
knowingly stolen documents from I don't
know where MLB gets a slush fund from
but let but so be it
I don't know I don't knock their hustle
either Rob Manfred was in charge of this
entire investigation but listen you got
out of Miami I mean we roll around in
the swamp you're gonna get some mud on
you
you gotta root this thing out I mean
you're in a way to cuz everybody was
saying you know how does how does the
NFL not get the TMZ tapes of all these
players that there that TMZ has the
tapes on yeah and the reason why they're
they're not gonna take some sort of
could you imagine if the NFL nobody
trusts could you imagine if the NFL took
a slush fund and gave it to somebody who
for whatever their reason wanted to leak
this tape when they had no right to
could you imagine you're assuming they
don't do that they don't otherwise they
don't because otherwise they'd have the
tape well in here well here's Harvey
Levin does here's what uh what they did
these convicted felons while they're
selling MLB the stolen documents for
cash and a diner
they had a buddy at another table with
an iPhone filming the transaction so
that they could sell the video of the
transaction to a-rod to say like hey you
can then release this but and they won't
ready
they're out windup getting scared about
this and they deleted it from the hard
drive and but they but a rod bought a
say blank harddrive from them for six
figures we have the wire transfer it's
in the documentary and they an a-rod
allegedly spent thousands more sending
the hard drive around the world to data
recovery services to try to get this
deleted footage back and unfortunately
couldn't and so we got footage America's
Sweetheart its hysterical I listen I
don't he was desperate and any you grew
up in Miami it's like sunny place for
shady people you know he's gonna it rubs
off on you and the the type of
characters you surround yourself do and
the fact that what do you think about it
the career of the highest-paid baseball
player in history effectively ended over
a four thousand dollar debt between a
cocaine addicted fake doctor and his
faked an addicted steroid patient it's
just kind of wonderful by the way Billy
Corbin you I mean now the fine point on
it I mean you stuck the landing on that
one and and and and that's why your
documentary is called screwball and I
guess we kind of buried the lead which
is a great way to finish up our
conversation here is there's so many
stories that required reenactment
because you don't have the footage
obviously of Toni Bosch talking to
Porter Fisher or Porter Fisher to boogie
who was
sky right I mean you don't have these
you have these these moments documented
with film so you recreated them using
children oh my god I can't I mean what
what why did you think that I have a
theory as to why I guess you said it at
the very beginning but because some of
the things these guys are saying it
sounds like they're five years old and
use use use kids who are like literally
what 8 10 12 years 9 10 yeah right
around they're saying the most foul
things yeah you know you're using Tony
Bosh's sit-down interview off-camera but
on camera or the kids mouthing were you
wearing hairpieces and dressed up facial
hair and we have to remember like when
we make sports documentaries like the
you 3434 example it's I don't mean to
knock our hustle it's still a
documentaries or a challenge to make but
the formula is clear you talk to sports
people sports people talk to you about
sports games you go get footage of
sports games and put sports game footage
on top of sports people talking about
sports that's that's how it goes here
this wasn't about sports yeah it was
baseball adjacent but all these events
occur in some shady fake doctor's clinic
in a locker room at a hotel at a bar at
a nightclub for example live in behind
me Beach the Fountainbleu and so what do
you do there's no footage so we did
recreations when you were gonna have to
and I was listening to the characters
talking during the interviews Tony and
Porter who don't like each other
spoiler alert they have a very similar
way of talking they talking dialogue
they're like I walked into his office
and I said where's my money and he said
I don't have your money and I said you
better get my money and he says what are
you gonna do about it
and I said I'm gonna break your neck I
appreciate you cleaning up the
conversations we could drunk history
this because they're talking to dialogue
so we have the actors lip-sync the
dialogue but the actors will all be 8 9
and 10 years old and not only did did it
strike me that they all acted like
children but it kind of works for me on
multiple layers not the least of which
is is that you know Tony Botti
ultimately and rightfully so went to
federal prison for not only treating
professional athletes but high school
kids
as well whose parents and coaches
brought them to Toni Bosch to try to get
an advantage in the in the draft and so
that combined with the fact that like I
said in the end we deal with this a
little bit the these athletes are heroes
and role models to young children and
they're sending a message loud and clear
and the kids are getting it because I do
q and A's with some of the actors the
young actors from the movie who answered
the question of the audience when they
say what is the moral of the story what
did you learn what are we supposed to
glean from all this and Bryan Blanco the
young kid who plays Tony Bosh in the lab
coat and everything he says oh I know I
know I'm like you don't don't raise your
hand it's a Q&A it's all yours dude the
floor is yours he's Ted what are you
gonna do he said lie cheat and steal and
that's how you win Oh No
and I'm like and when it comes from him
it's a little more depressing than when
I say it but the truth of matter is this
is these are the lessons that were
teaching our children now one in this I
mean one in this I know obviously alex
is a totally new life and a new
reputation and he's living it and he's
living it well but Tony Bosh is he
convicted felon I didn't see I didn't
look at anybody in this movie and say
these people of one you know I mean and
and I honestly not not a single person
comes off like anything positive in a
way in this whole situation although
again I don't blame baseball for doing
whatever that kid needed to do to
tribute this thing out that's that's my
belief but just seeing at the end of
this thing Pedro Gomez came out fine so
look Billy this is this is just this is
truly something else man
but last one for you here did you
believe Tony Bosh I mean cuz the guy's
using he's still referring to people he
was treating his patients I mean come on
now that did you dig it goes to jail
obviously he's got a story to tell but
he also has I'll tell you one person who
believes in Tony Bosh is Tony Bosh that
man has a lot of self-confidence and and
despite the fact that he went to medical
school in Belize what one of our
interview subjects refers to as the
Belize School of the medical and
Performing Arts he very much is a true
believer in his own ability and I will
tell you this guy didn't do at
traditional advertising because this was
very much a grey market business at
he he was thrived on word-of-mouth and
he got that word of mouth because he got
results for his clients so he was doing
something right and I'll tell you one of
the epilogues we didn't get to do in the
in the movies and ran out of time and
money but um Tony winds up in minimum
security federal prison a camp in
Alabama and he is there teaching
nutrition to his fellow inmates a Jeff
Skilling from Enron is there no changing
business to their fellow inmates and
Jesse Jackson jr. is in prison they're
teaching political science and civics to
his fellow inmates and yeah I mean
listen we're just trying to manga trying
to make a rod great again that's what
we're trying to do dr. Hannibal Lecter
is teaching a class oh my gosh Billy
thanks for coming on man you made a
great film check out screwball in select
cities this Friday and then on numerous
streaming platforms the Friday after
that at Billy Corbin on Twitter and
Instagram good to see you brother thanks
back with more in a moment the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience